ich habe eine revolution geplant eine
ganz neue bewegung nach der wm jetzt
unser leben leben werden ist dass die
betriebe herzen kommt sollen die leute
herkommen zu einem video das ich mich
ganz besonders freuen wir uns heute eine
folge von cras klassen vertrat sie das
ganze ist besonders fanny wahlkreis
klassenfahrt ja quasi von youtube
gemacht dass atv ist ja von jonas ems
und das wird gemacht und quasi tv von
youtube für youtube und andererseits
dazu kommt noch leute dass ich kurz vor
kroner einfach mit so gefühlt der
gesamten besetzung von cras klassenfahrt
in berlin feiern war also habe ich die
auf mittlerweile schon kennengelernt und
schon sehr gespannt wie das ist jetzt
dienen so der folge zu sehen ich würde
sagen heute wir reden gar nicht lange
drum herum und starten direkt rein ins
kuvert lebst du nach der bibel von katja
h
möglicherweise sache die projekte merken
die dialoge sind auf jeden fall
orientiert an dem niveau von häfen und
konsorten also von hdtv und sind aber
youtube referenzen eingebaut also
querverweise auf das was auf youtube so
gerade passiert hier wird vorgeworfen
dass sie dachte hatte belebt von katja
es ist natürlich in berg nachdem ich
persönlich auch lebe also bin ich sehr
gespannt wie sie so drauf ist
die ganzen mädels aus der klasse von
tyler beechey region zu bekehren richtig
darum geht es mir nicht
es geht mir um das selbstbewusstsein der
frau ok ok moment wo sind wir jetzt
überhaupt also wir haben hier einen
etwas korpulentere detektiv in klamotten
als würde er eigentlich in england
arbeiten und nicht in deutschland bei
kras klassenfahrt ihm gegenüber haben
wir eine junge leicht bekannte dame er
wirft ihr vor dass sie die [ __ ]
religion von katja casa bitte weiter
verbreiten will sie hingegen ein
es geht um selbstbewusstsein ok also
schlampig sowie der und ich bin wirklich
relativ blind hier rein gestattet ich
habe mich bewusst nicht intensiv damit
auseinandergesetzt was gerade so die
storyline bei klassenfahrten ist man von
ungefilterten eindruck davon zu bekommen
und ich muss sagen ich bin etwas
überrascht mehr
[Musik]
als er das gesehen gerade gesicht
abgelegt das 5 1 ist das denn
ok also ich hab diesen kleinen party
übersprung und in fahrt von einigen
minuten sogar wo es eigentlich darum
geht dass jonas also dass eine
stilberatung von anderswo kommt das habe
ich es nicht ganz geschickt gegen das
virus gibt aber hier geht es weiter in
der in der story nachdem gerade eben der
englische detektiv der aus
unerfindlichen gründen in deutschland
arbeitet sie tesla und wie sie heißt
[Gelächter]
religionen konfrontiert hat geht es
jetzt weiter und ein mädchen filmt ein
hund im wald ok gucken was es damit auf
sich habe
inzwischen gut gefunden ich weiß nicht
bist du heidi ich kenne keine heilig
been a là là là
ich weiß nicht was ich jetzt machen soll
vega ist dieser uns ich weiß nicht was
ist das ist habe ich einen zwergspitz
oder sowas also ich glaube auch nicht
alle von euch da draußen sind hunde
menschen aber ich bin sicher einige
nicht ist es einen zwergspitz oder ein
mittel spitz ich weiß es nicht da aber
die hätte also ich bin wirklich
eigentlich nicht so ein krasser fern von
klein und muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
aber der ist schon gut
ich weiß nicht was ich jetzt machen soll
du hast das einfache gefunden ja einfach
da hinten ich wollte gerade ich weiß
schon öfters aber ich wollte jetzt hat
wieder zum gehen
aber ist ja eigentlich absolut gar
nichts also muss sagen die dialoge sind
sind schon sehr relativ wertvoll die
dialoge sind sehr wertvoll leute also da
hat man sich auf jeden fall schauen am
vorbild orientiert ich muss auch mal
ganz klar sagen nur falls ihr jedes land
bekommt dass das nicht so wäre bei mir
ich bin tatsächlich ein fan von kraft
klassenfahrt also ich schaffe bin nicht
so ein fan der formal ist das regelmäßig
schauer oder so aber ich bin die idee
cool ich find's cool das jupa sowas
selbst machen feierlich mega
ich weiß nicht aber wir können sie
einfach behalten oder als haustiere und
ja es ist wirklich zu krass meinst du
die gehört irgendwem mit nein natürlich
nicht was das für eine frage die
allermeisten hunde gehören keimen und
schlagen sich einfach in unserer
zivilisierten welt in deutschland
einfach selbst durch und gehen selbst
arbeiten sehr viele hunde bewusst ihr
wahrscheinlich nicht arbeiten den
supermärkten im lager zum beispiel und
transportieren der sache von a nach b
sieht man meistens nicht aber so können
die hunde selbstständig überleben so zum
beispiel auch dieser hund dieser hund
arbeitet beim rewe
es ist so einfach nicht wollte auch
schon immer ein hund haben aber ich war
einzelkind und ich war schüchtern aber
dieser runde könnte mein leben verändern
[Gelächter]
diese der die dialoge sind wirklich geil
ist geil gemacht sind sehr fanny dieses
mädchen analysieren ist mal ganz kurz
wollte ihr ganzes leben lang hund sie es
ging einfach nicht sie konnte einfach
keine handhabe weil sie waren einzeln
ich habe dazugehört muss ich sagen aber
es war überhaupt ein ziehkind oder so
und das ging einfach nicht und es ist
ganz traurig für sie aber dann was
passiert sie läuft alles tages durch
wald einfach ein fachanwalt und dann
läuft ihre ich sag jetzt einfach mal
zwergspitz über den weg ich weiß jetzt
wie wälder in deutschland integriert es
natürlich wohnen schnitt von zwerg
spitzen sind müssen wir sagen nein ich
habe eine revolution geplant eine ganz
neue bewegung nach der wert jetzt unser
leben leben werden ist dass die betriebe
können wir noch mal auf den inhalt
eingehen also die serie negativer die
betriebe ich glaube dass das wirklich
das ist wirklich ein buch aus katar
kaiserwetter rausgebracht hat ne ich
gerade
ja ja ja einfach die bibel
gib mir deine kies zu den bands sie
nennen mich einen posten bei uns zu
meinen namen bis die ganze nachbarschaft
ihn auch kennt hier liest du four das
ist es wird jetzt ganz schwer
einzuordnen ist es absurd dass er
bewusst absolut gemacht aber es ist
trotzdem obwohl man weiß dass die beiden
jonas mekas last und machen das mit
absicht gemacht haben trotzdem ist es
noch wirklich es ist schwere kost leute
sagen wie es ist es ist schwere kost
aber wenn wir darüber nachdenken leute
ist gibt doch bestimmt leute in
deutschland die so leben es gibt doch
bestimmt leute für die katja das
allergrößte ist also im kern sportlich
auch diese idee von selbstbestimmt
hätten zu bisschen seinen eigenen weg
gehen und sich nicht so krass in so eine
vorgefertigte rollen zwängen lassen von
der gesellschaft aber auch katja jetzt
das richtige tool für unsere jugend ist
das war es jetzt auch nicht die typen
aus plastik von gummi auf asphalt
sie hätten aber mache nichts dass
deutschland jugend ist lacht man nicht
leute ist es deutschland jugend es ist
ein signifikanter teil der mädels in
deutschland die katja gasser wird die
jüngeren sind also leute mal ganz im
ernst wenn ihr mal ein paar jahre auf
der erde gelebt hat sage ich mal wenn
ihr mal mitte 20 sei aber so was wie ich
dann werdet ihr die erkenntnis gemacht
haben dass es wirklich für jeden scheiß
leute gebieten feiern
und die ist geisteskrank feiern und es
gibt egal was man sich ausdenkt weil ich
was so ein geist krankes auslegen kann
es gibt leute die es machen ach so kann
ich auch wirklich mit an sicherheit
grenzender wahrscheinlichkeit sagen dass
radikale hat er je mehr in deutschland
gibt und viele davon
das sind die worte unserer neuen göttin
nach denen werden wir uns jetzt richten
wo front aber für die jünger von katar
kasse sind die noch ein bisschen leicht
angezählt viele angezogen
ich glaube so wenn man so kaffeekasse
wettringer ist dann darf also um die ich
glaube so 100 quadratzentimeter stoff am
körper tragen also 100 quadratzentimeter
sind so zehn zentimeter mal zehn
zentimeter so das darf man im ganzen
körper haben
hey was müssen hier los mit dem motto ja
klar wir haben muss das ist wahr die
gerade war auch mit dabei war in berlin
also ich muss aber sagen heute ist an
die für mich leute die ich jetzt
eigentlich erst mal außerhalb
kennengelernt habe die ich so irgendwie
irgendwelchen runden beim feiern oder so
kennengelernt habe jetzt auch hier in
den kreisklassen vater meinen videos zu
sehen als atemberaubend und ich meine
kian oder wer ist in der rolle fly
glaube ich frei kommt natürlich zum
richtigen zeitpunkt hier in dieses
setting rheinland zu dem zeitpunkt wo
drei junge mädels gerade von dedic
religion indoktriniert wurden gehört
jetzt immer wieder eine ganze ecke
später was passiert jetzt
man kennt im winter
frau b das ist wirklich kümmert es ist
thomas d ich kann nicht leute nicht ich
kann nicht mehr tv-sendungen reinziehen
oder es mit der mentalität des jetzt
also sachen reinzieht und dann haben
auch eine band leute gesehen die ich aus
meinem privaten leben kenne das geht
nicht da muss mir kurz unternehmen das
gibt es nicht okay leute ich hab jetzt
mein kaffee getrunken beruhigt habe ich
mich hier nicht
und ja wir sehen hier revier in seinem
gt 63 amg anfährt und den den boss
markiert muss man davon klar sagen und
geisteskrank auge macht auch frau war
also auf wo war sie auf sie hier
allerdings das ist ja das ist frau war
okay
ich komme im blick leute wenn ihr auf
der straße unterwegs seid ihr seht ihr
wie der ich mit diesem blick anschaut
dann bedenkt hier seit den großen klub
also leute ich habe wirklich sie wovon
der handlung geschenk muss ich ganz
ehrlich zugeben ich muss wirklich sagen
feier dass das es sowas von youtube
gemacht gibt findet man das ganze in
zumindest für mich als auch youtuber
alles für euch als youtube zuschauer
vielleicht auch sympathischer als wenn
es irgendwo fernsehkonzern macht keine
ahnung über auf jeden fall gut wird
leute die man erst so getroffen hat und
kennen gelernt hat dann danach bei kras
klassenfahrt zu sehen aber so ist das
leben für euch geht jetzt wenn ihr nicht
selbst von katar sawicki jungen
attackiert werden wollt dann klickt ihr
einfach vorstellungsvideo apa bonität um
ein kanal in der stadt raus was gut so